President Trump says that Congress has a
once-in-a-generation opportunity to pass
a sweeping tax overhaul the Republican
plan introduced us yesterday would
create three individual income tax
brackets
they are twelve twenty five and thirty
five percent Republicans say
middle-class Americans will benefit from
nearly doubling the standard deduction
and boosting the child care tax credit
but Senate Democratic leader Chuck
Schumer said the plan with its corporate
cuts and elimination of the estate tax
largely benefits the rich Treasury
Secretary Stephen venusian joins us now
from the Treasury Department in
Washington secretary Minuten good
morning good morning it's great to be
here with you tax reform or tax cuts are
hard because you have to pay for them
and either you have to increase the
growth of the economy or you have to
have additional increases in spending
our decreases in spending and people
worry that if you don't produce the
economic growth you're gonna have to cut
spending and that means cutting
entitlements what happens if you don't
have the economic growth Charlie I think
you know we're very comfortable the
president's number one focus is creating
economic growth and that's a combination
a tax reform regulatory relief and trade
and we're very comfortable we're going
to get to three percent GDP which
creates over two trillion dollars of
revenues and ten trillion dollars of
economic growth but you know that's an
assumption many people disagree with
that you can't reach in 2018 more than
three percent growth well there's some
people that disagree but most people
agree and I would just remind you the
Obama projections were substantially
higher than that but they only were at
2% because of various different policies
coming out of the financial crisis well
secretary you know the critics are
speaking up very loudly they say the
rich only get richer why is that not the
case well as I've said before the
president is committed that this is
really about a middle income tax cut
simplifying personal taxes and making
our corporations and pass-throughs
competitive with the rest of the world
mr. secretary cabinet members like
yourself have come under criticism for
the use of private planes and expensive
military government military planes as
well can you promise the American
taxpayer
when it's on their dime and for the rest
of your the remainder of your tenure in
office that you will use commercial
aircraft and air flights I can promise
the American taxpayer the only time that
I will be using mill air is when there
are issues either for national security
or where we have to get to various
different things there's no other means
with respect to the corporate
repatriation how do you guarantee that
those funds that the corporation's will
then have will be used to account for
economic growth to build plants to hire
new people and create jobs well Charlie
we're we're very comfortable with the
concept of there's going to be a
one-time tax on what we call deemed
repatriation you can think of it
effectively it's paying at all on going
from a worldwide system to a territorial
system as a result of that I think we'll
get back somewhere between two and four
trillion dollars it's just an incredible
amount of money that will come back here
and we're very comfortable that the
combination of that and immediate
expensing is going to create massive
investment in the United States can we
focus on the lowest tax bracket
increases for just a second we have the
numbers here that it increases to 12%
from 10% so how do you justify the
increase on some of the country's lowest
earners it doesn't increase at all what
they're raising the standard deduction
effectively the 10% bracket will
disappear and I can assure you there
will be nobody that was in the 10% that
will be paying higher taxes what's the
timetable for getting this through
Congress we're committed to getting this
to the president to sign in December so
we're expecting that the house begins
the markup in October they got a lot of
work to do the Senate will work along
with them we got a lot of people in
Treasury that are working with us that
are helping the staff and we're going to
move this very very fast secretary
minuchin thank you for joining us this
morning
thank you appreciate it